Hello everyone. Once again, happy Monday. Here we are Monday again. The week seemed to just fly by. So I hope everybody had a good weekend.
And thank you guys for re-registering for the Zoom calls. So we were having some technical issues and every once in a while it is good for us to kind of refresh and get a new
meeting ID and refresh the Zoom call information. So thank you for re-registering. Okay. So we are going to start off here with our questions that have come in.
And then we have, we don't have a lot of questions. And obviously the Wednesday call last week, Dr. Conner's cancelled kind of last minute, had something going on. So apologize for that.
So we'll get these questions answered. Just entering people in here.
Let's see. Okay. So here we go. The first one. So with my pancreatic cancer case, I'm told to avoid dairy. I wanted to try the Budwig protocol that has cottage cheese. I understand that the flax oil in the recipe counters the dairy when mixed properly.
Can I safely use the Budwig protocol knowing this? Yes. So this is kind of the one exception we allow when we've asked you to avoid dairy on your protocol.
We do support use of the Budwig protocol. So it's kind of the one time we make the dairy exception is when you are doing the Budwig protocol. So certainly you can can start that. And it is a good idea to ask us, you know, ask us about this prior to starting.
For one reason, just to, you know, kind of get it in your notes that you're, you're trying the Budwig protocol, but then there might be a scenario where we really don't want you to do it because of the dairy, but most often it is, it is fine. So yes, you can add that to your protocol.
All right, question about foot bath programs. Excuse me. So this person is referring to the new programs. She just got updated programs. And she says, the first time I did program three, it came with a stench today. I did program three again. And now my hip joints hurt. They did not hurt before this.
What do you think this is? Do you think it's just temporary? Any ideas to bring comfort? So, so what do we think it is? Well, it's, you know, kind of hard to say exactly what it is, but certainly when we are introducing new things to a protocol. So in this case, we've got some new frequencies that she's introducing through the foot bath.
It is creating a response within the body that is different than something you probably have previously previously experienced. So certainly could be just your body's response to these frequencies.
The programs that you're running are most likely cancer based frequencies for your specific diagnosis.
And therefore, you know, certainly if there's any, you know, cancer in the hips, I don't know that there is for this particular person. I don't think there is, but, you know, any time, again, you're, you're just introducing something new to the body. The body has a response. And maybe it's just some inflammation in that area because for whatever reason that particular area is where the inflammation is, you know, just kind of going to for whatever specific reason.
So, you know, certainly just stay hydrated, keep up with your supplements, you know, take it easy. Maybe you space out your foot baths a little, a little farther, the stench that you reference.
And kind of the colors, you know, that's normal. It is normal to have some smell. Some odd smells when it is relating to the foot bath.
And certainly the color changes normal as well. Yes, I think it is just temporary. Your body will get used to it and your body will adjust. And as we get these frequencies into the body, you know, they're creating the response and doing their job. So we're fighting that cancer.
And, you know, if you're doing some detoxing frequencies, you know, we're getting the toxins out of the body. So it's all good.
I think it is just temporary. Just give yourself a little extra rest and a little extra TLC. Don't push things.
It's probably just a little bit of an inflammatory response. So anything that is anti inflammatory can help bring you some comfort.
So curcumin can help buzzwellia can help. Don't know if you have the aloeva immune product or excuse me, the aloeva limit list. That's the one that is made from beet roots and that is the active ingredient of the beta line, which works really great as an anti inflammatory.
So you could try that. You could try some
inflammation programs on the right machine as well.
And so here she's referencing the colors of the water. Yes, so the colors get very murky. So that is is normal.
Okay, so this question is referring to blood work. They're kind of going into details on the specific results of
their blood work. The bottom line is that they have some low white blood cell numbers, a specific white blood cell, neutrophils are coming up as low. So anytime somebody sends in a question regarding labs, you know, we can't really give a true recommendation or a true analysis of what's going on
because I personally have not looked at your labs and for this person, I don't know, you know, kind of I'm not working with them one on one. And so I don't know the health
health history background, what exactly they've got going on. So I can't give specific recommendations and I can't tell you exactly what's going on with these results for those reasons. If you do want specific information
regarding any lab results, you do have to schedule with with Dr. Conner's that one on one appointment to go over the lab work and he can give you his his opinion. So with all of that being said, we can kind of talk in general term.
So what we're doing with the zoom calls is kind of trying to educate and speak in general terms. So again, this is not a specific advice on what to do based on this scenario, because I don't have all the ins and outs of this specific scenario. So in general terms, when we're talking about white blood cells and having low white blood cells, you know, it's white blood cells are for
inflammation. So they're part of the immune immune response in attacking pathogens. And so that can create some inflammation. And so having high white blood cell
counts can mean that your body is fighting that infection and creating some of that inflammation. So in this scenario, she's got some low white blood cell counts. And so what are reasons than that that that can happen. Well, certainly if anybody is on chemotherapy.
She's got that messes with your blood cell counts and certainly can lower white blood cell counts. And that's one of the reason that they are checking levels. They don't want your white blood cell count to get too low because then you are vulnerable to
infections. And they may even skip a chemotherapy session if count blood cell counts are too low. So it could be, I don't know if this person is on chemotherapy or not could be because of that could be
when there's low white blood cell count, it could be because of a chronic viral infection. You know, it could be, you know, other kind of blood issues going on could be stressed related.
You know, there's a number of reasons that blood numbers are can be off. And certainly this is just one test. So Dr. Conner just talked about this a lot when we're taking lab results, you know, we have to kind of take things with the grain of salt. This is just one snippet of time at that
moment when you are having your blood draw and and lab values do depend on what's going on in that certain scenario. And the the blood that they've collected at that time, that's not, you know, conclusive of exactly what's going on within the body, it is a tool. So it gives us a part of the picture, but we, you know, kind of need to look at multiple lab results and see trends and not just
hyper focus on a specific blood level. So in this case, you know, what can we do to kind of naturally boost white blood cell count so we can, you know, do anything that can increase the immune system to help just boost the immune system.
There's supplements you can take.
Evolva immune, so that's a great supplement to help boost the immune system.
So if you did a Google search on our or not a Google search, but a search on our web store for just immune supplements, you know, we have an immune boosting bundle so you can, you know, kind of look at the supplements there.
Anything to help stimulate the immune system, you can certainly run programs on the right machine to help stimulate the immune system. There is a vitamin C, a vitamin C program on the right machine you can run that you can take vitamin C, you can take garlic.
Anything to help with that and certainly just, you know, getting adequate nutrition, make sure you're getting, you know, enough fruits and vegetables, antioxidants, you're getting enough sleep.
So all of these things that we're asking you to do in your protocol are all to help, you know, normalize function throughout the body.
So hopefully that gives you some ideas to kind of help help boost white blood cell count and again, without knowing the specifics of this situation, you know, this is just general advice and education.
Okay, next question. So this question is being an older female and since I am on a no dairy low histamine diet, should I be taking a calcium supplement.
So I encourage all of you and this person in particular to check out Dr. our blog and just type calcium into the search bar and you will come up with this article here that Dr. Conner's wrote talking about calcium and should I take a calcium supplement.
And here are some of the key points in that article. So really calcium. First of all, it kind of depends on the reasons why you would be taking calcium. I'm assuming in this scenario she's concerned about bone health.
And really all of our minerals calcium included we need to be looking at the form because there's lots of junkie forms of minerals that really do nothing for the body calcium and all minerals should be taken, you know, as as close to a whole food source as possible.
So we get minerals from our foods that we eat. So if we're eating a variety of fruits, vegetables, plant-based foods, we are getting minerals there.
Yes, you can supplement, but again, it needs to be in the right forms. And if you're looking at our store and you you do a search for minerals.
Those minerals that we have on our store are the correct forms. They need to be bound with something attached to something, you know, like a glycinate or or a specific molecule, a proper molecule so that your body can absorb them.
So calcium carbonate is basically, you know, not a good form that would be like eating a rock, you know, your body just can't absorb some of these lower quality forms of minerals that you know you would buy at Walmart or CVS or something. So quality matters. And so take a look at our mineral supplements.
They're from or there's there's a patented place, you know, for proper mineral minerals in supplement form and that's called tracks so that acronym TRA CCS is kind of what you're looking for for quality mineral forms.
And then Dr. Conner's notes in this article that you should not exceed 500 milligrams a day too much calcium is not good even in the correct form can, you know, cause some build up and affect the cardiovascular system needs to be balanced with other minerals and nutrients.
So taking something like our clear multi-min plus that does have calcium in it would be something that would be good. So in combination with other minerals calcium deficiency is not the cause of osteoporosis.
And so, you know, if we're looking to prevent osteoporosis or, you know, help treat osteoporosis calcium is not the best way taking calcium is not the best way to to work with that.
osteoporosis is an inflammatory disease not a not a mineral deficiency disease. So we do have a bone building bundle that you can take a look at. Dr. Conner talks about the best ways to decrease inflammation in the bone.
Using a product called TVGO that's high in EGCG, which is the best way to reduce inflammation that IEL6 pathway that triggers inflammation in the bone.
So taking that would be good. And then he states that taking FOSOMax or other similar drugs to prevent bone loss plain and simple just does not work.
So, so certainly calcium can be taken just in general to support, you know, mineral function and health, but that's not the best way to support bone health.
So some of those other ways and if you look at that bone building bundle, that would be a better way to support bone health.
So certainly read this article goes into more detail about that.
All right, spending some significant time a little bit off grid electricity, but no running water. How will my foot bath do with rain water with creek water?
So this is awesome. I'm glad you're getting off grid and taking a little bit of time with nature and away from the hustle and bustle. So that is therapy in itself.
Enjoy your time. Certainly you can bring your right equipment and foot baths and while I don't know specifically the answer to this question, I cannot imagine that that there would be any problem with using rain water or creek water.
Obviously you still want to put the salt, the sea salt or the Himalayan salt into the tub and try to get the water to be as free from debris as possible, but really it's just the water itself, the hydrogen and the oxygen that are creating the conductivity in combination with the salt to help with the foot bath and the frequencies entering the body through that conductivity.
So I don't see a problem with it. It might change conductivity. You know, you know, depending on, you know, what minerals are in the water and how much salt you use, it does change the conductivity. So I don't know. So you might have an increased accelerated response with the frequencies in your body.
So you'll just have to watch for that. But certainly I don't think there's a problem with the right itself and using rain water or creek water. So I would say go for it and let us know how it goes.
All right general question regarding CT scans and how accurate they are. I've had three CT scans of the pelvic area now for colorectal tumor.
Two with contrast one without I'm using these measure using these to measure measure progress. The only problem is that they are very inconsistent also have had several MRIs done all done since March 11th of 2020.
So yes, so certainly no test is perfect. So what you are experiencing.
You know, absolutely there's inconsistencies and I'm going to let Dr Conner's going to more detail on this on the Wednesday Zoom call. I know I believe this person, you know, he was referencing Dr Conner's but I just thought that I would throw part of his question in here to just kind of address this in a more general way.
Because, you know, it is a common question, you know, we get lab results back, you know, just like we spoke about moments ago lab results back and you know we're focused on one part and what are these results mean and you know really it's when we are looking at the trends in these results where there is value and certainly in relation to other results does this does these results align with how you feel do they align with other test results that you're getting.
Take every test with a grain of salt. There is no perfect test that gives you an exact, you know, kind of reading of of tumor growth or size or where you're at so certainly you're you're in a different position when you have scan CT scans and MRI scans or there's no way to be in the exact same position to truly exactly measured tumor.
So you might be at a slightly different angle so they're getting a slightly different measurement so everything has kind of a margin of error.
So there's a small, you know, small changes in size, you know, is it within the margin of error and is it, you know, consistent with other scans or data that we're collecting to really assess how you're doing.
So I have to check for that certainly technology can be different so if you're, you know, I don't know if this person is going to the same clinic using the same machine so technology can be different depending on the machines that you're using.
Just kind of a little personal story here and I hope people don't mind that I share personal stories once in a while I know this call is about you guys, but, you know, just having my own cancer experience with my husband, you know, I can relate and this question reminds me of a time when my husband had brain cancer so he was diagnosed almost 11 years ago.
Doing great, doing well, but has, you know, had a number of MRIs to just kind of check and it's probably about five years ago he had an MRI and, you know, red flags were up, something was different on this one and the oncologist kind of immediately went to okay, this is change, we think this is growth, we need to get you in for that biopsy.
You need to schedule with your neural surgeon right away and so of course all of these, you know, horrible gut-wrenching feelings come up and you're, you're panicked and you're afraid and you, you know, you don't want your mind to go to these dark places, but you can't help it.
So we scheduled the appointment with a neurologist, you know, a couple of few days later and sitting for hours in the waiting room, I'll never forget, you know, it's where we were waiting for two hours for our appointment, he was behind schedule and the whole time, you know, my mind is, is stewing like oh my gosh, here we go again, it's been five years, everything's been going so well.
Just that total, you know, blow to the gut and to the heart when you think here, here we go again and so we get into the meeting with the oncologist, excuse me, the neurosurgeon and he is just kind of like, hold on a second here, you know, I know the oncologist, you know, wants to stay ahead of things and but they're jumping way too far ahead, we have had an update in the technology on this MRI machine.
And so this in this particular scenario, he said that he really thinks that the changes that we're seeing were because of this update to this new technology, where it might, the change might have not been picked up in the previous version because it just wasn't as sensitive and now they've done this update and it's more sensitive and so it's probably it's showing something different, but doesn't necessarily mean that it is growth.
And so obviously that was music to our ears, you know, to think okay, you know, this isn't, you know, we don't need to jump to that conclusion, we need to just weigh this and in this case, that was exactly what it was, you know, and he said so let's just wait and not jump there yet and we'll come back in three months and and check do another MRI and see and at that point if we do see changes then.
You know, we might need to do some more investigating, but so we did that we followed up in another three months and everything was fine and stable and all is good and now it's been almost 11 years so all of that story is just to say technology changes nothing is perfect, we can't get hung up on one scan, we need to look at trends not just one one result so like I said.
Doctor Connors will kind of go into more detail about the accuracy of scans and results, but I just wanted to kind of touch on that and thank you for listening to my personal story, but I think you know it relates and I hope that it can kind of help and I love hearing all of your guys's stories because certainly I can relate and just know that.
You know, we we feel for you every step of the way and we are here to walk with you alongside all of the test results and even though we have to stay in our lane and we can't make recommendations from a conventional perspective, we do we do understand and we'll do the best that we can to support you with every every step and every choice.
So that was all of the questions that came in so now we'll kind of look at chat questions.
Let's see seems like the new rife programs are not causing any pain like the old programs is that normal.
Certainly it can be normal do know that when we have changed your programs we're not as far as cancer frequencies are concerned and individual diagnosis we're not removing cancer frequencies we are just actually concentrating the cancer frequencies and.
You know so doctor Conner's programming was a little different than Michelle's so if Michelle originally programmed your equipment and now the new update you know you might have just one week's worth of programs where you had two or three weeks with Michelle so really doctor Conner's.
You know way that he is approaching the rife frequencies is you know to kind of concentrate and specify for for the cancer and he wants more time obviously spent with those cancer fighting frequencies where there was some ancillary things that were maybe tested and they were in Michelle's programming.
And you certainly can run other things on the general programs with the rife machine but the programs doctor Conner's have created are concentrated cancer fighting frequencies so you're not getting less of anything cancer related and then from the change from just the new version and the update.
Again we're not changing those programs were just changing the order of the frequencies and how the actual programming is done because it needs to be done a little different from other the version five software to the new version six software.
So all of that being said the way your body responds if you're feeling like your body is responding a little differently it yeah absolutely can be normal you know your body might respond differently just because it's a different time your body is is more used to those frequencies now we've done a lot of that preliminary work and adjusting whereas it was new and so your body had a lot of adjusting to do now your bodies used to it.
And it's you know worked on some of those the detox pathways so your body changes and so your body's response can change so can be normal does vitamin B 17 help with killing cancer so yes so it can be a cancer fighting supplement we do test cancer fighting supplements so the supplement protocol that we have you on.
If it does not include B 17 that's because it wasn't testing as the best cancer fighting supplement for you specifically does not mean that you can add something if you feel compelled to do that.
It just means that we have created a protocol based on our testing which includes the the cancer fighting supplements that tested as specifically for you to balance your cancer so we want you to take those.
Anything that you take in addition to you certainly can and with subsequent testing different things might come up so.
B 17 can be yes a cancer fighting supplement does hear some protocol lower white blood cell count i have read that a lot of raw foods can can you know kind of change or lower white blood cell count so possibly i don't know that for sure but i did.
Read something indicating that that might be a reason for kind of a fall you know a low blood cell count would be eating a lot of raw foods.
So you can take that into consideration i did my foot bath this morning with creek water use salt as usual the water wasn't as murky as usual i did get a few burps from the machine though and thoughts so yes so.
Different you know minerals and different composition of the water can create you know different conductivity so i'm glad that the color of the water did change so it was was working but not as murky as usual so.
So again just could be because of the different water that you're using the burps are normal from the machine and that just is because of the hydrogen that is on you know.
What what the metal plate is doing is kind of attracting the hydrogen atoms the positively charged atoms to one side and the negatively charged.
Oxygen atoms to the other side and then you know it's creating that conductivity so those burps and bubbles are from the hydrogen and that is normal so that's fine as well alright so fun a foot bath in nature with creek water sounds like a perfect scenario glad you did that.
Alright any other questions i'll see anything else coming in so just a reminder as usual to utilize that patient membership site in the little search bar here if you're doing a search.
You're doing a search from from the actual membership page it's not going to bring up just content from the membership site if you're doing a search it's going to bring up content from the blog which is great you know to do a search from the blog but just an FYI somebody was asking about that so yes but utilize that utilize that blog utilize the membership site.
It's a place to go to get announcements and information past zoom calls only shows videos from 322 am I missing something so yes so on the zoom call page so if you click this little tab right here brings up you know all of the information about logging into the zoom call all of that stuff and then towards the bottom there is a video.
There's a snapshot of a video screen there's a tab that says doctor Connors and there's a tab that says and and so those are you know doctor Connors zoom calls if you're on his tab in mine if you're on my tab so those are kind of the current most current.
Zoom calls and it's it's on a playlist so every call that we record we add to a playlist and so the most recent recording will always be the one that is.
We're viewed in that screen when you click on those tabs and you can actually click on the middle of those images there and it will play the recording so the most recent recording is always that first one there and if you were to just let that you know you listen to the whole thing and it will just.
Scroll or loop into that the next zoom call from the previous week so again a playlist is showing just housing all of those zoom calls.
So you can access all of those same with with mine so I think this is maybe my sixth one so all six of those are on a playlist and if you watch that first one and let it go then it will loop right into that second third fourth six one so you can watch all of those.
That button on the very bottom that you can click on it and it says a link to pass to zoom calls yes that only shows it shows starting from you know 2017 or something and it goes through more current ones but the last one that's listed there is from 322 so that's kind of the old way or the previous way that we were logging all of the zoom calls so we just.
Had that log and we'd copy and paste the link and but now the more recent ones are on the playlist embedded within that those tabs on that zoom call screen so hopefully that helps that's a good question and that's not the first time that question has been asked so good question.
You are very welcome all right any other questions I don't see any other questions coming through so you guys have a wonderful rest of your day and keep sending in those questions dr. Connor will be back on the Wednesday zoom call and look forward to talking with you guys again on Monday have a great week bye bye.